ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะเคยหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดิหาร
ไม่เป็นไรโอเค
เนี่ยไม่ดูนักเรียนฟังภาษาไทย
พอดแคสต์มาโรงเรียน
ไม่ต้องดูค่ะฐานนี้วันอะไร
ควันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 23 ค่ะค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่
คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต
2564 ปีคศอะไรคะเมื่อปีคศ 2  021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันพุธค่ะวันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพุธที่ 22 ค่ะเดือนเดือนธันวาคมเป็น
เดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ปีพตต
2564 ปีคศ
2  021 ค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันศุกร์ที่ 24 เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะสิ้น
เดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพตต
ปีพตปี
2564 ปีคศ 2  021
1 ให้หลุยส์ 24 ไง
คริสมาสต์อีฟ
ตื่นเต้น
คนไทยชอบทำอะไรชอบ Christmas อ๋อ
ประเทศไทยไม่มีคลิปมากอีกมั้ยไม่มีหาไม่
มีอะไร
ไม่มีอะไรแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
ภูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 12:00 น
เที่ยงกี่นาทีคะสามสิบสองนาทีค่ะเที่ยง
สามสิบสองนาที
เนาะครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยัง
ฝากินข้าวแล้วค่ะกินข้าวแล้วผู้หญิงกิน
ข้าวหรือยังคะกินแล้วค่ะ More  in
แล้ว
อ่ะเห็นรูปฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วก็ฟ้ากินเนี่ย
ฟัดทำอาหารไหมทำเองไหมข้าวที่กูฟ้ากินครู
ฟ้าทำ
ออกไม่ได้ทำหงอคงฝาซื้อซื้อแต่กูฟ้าทำ
อาหารได้นะ
สมัยอย่างในรูปใช่ไหมเด็กผู้ชายทำอาหาร
ครูบา 5 ทำอาหารเต้นหรอคะทำอาหารเป็นค่ะ
โอ๋แล้วเวลากูฟ้าทำอาหารเสร็จแล้วก็กิน
อร่อยไหม
คิดว่าอะไร
คิดว่าหรอ
องศาถ้าทำครูฟ้าชื่อเล่นแล้วกูฟ้าก็คิด
อร่อยอร่อยค่ะใช่
โอเคครับวิธีนะครูหญิงทำอาหารเป็นไหมคะ
เป็นฆ่าผู้หญิงทำอาหารเบนซ์
อร่อยไหมคะ
อันนี้อะไรอะดาผู้หญิงคิดธรรมดา
กินได้กินอ่ะโอเคโอเคกินได้
แต่ครูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงเนี่ยทำอาหารเป็นแต่
ไม่ได้ทำเป็นทุกๆเมนู
ใช้ได้นะทำอะไรเป็นบ้างอ่ะเนาะวันนี้แหละ
ผู้หญิงก็จะมีรูปภาพอาหารเนาะเราจะมาถาม
ว่าอาหารเมนูนี้ครูฟ้าทำเป็นไหมนายขได้
ค่ะอันที่ 1 อันที่ 1 เอาง่ายๆก่อนเลย
เนาะครูฟ้าดูแล้วก็คิดว่าอันนี้อะไรคะ
กูก็บ่ s-off
Hot ไก่ทอดอันนี้คือไก่ทอดค่า
อ๋อเป็น 4 ไก่ด้วยไก่ก็น่ารัก FC ไหมกาย
เหมือนๆ KFC เนอะไก่ทอดน่องครูฟ้าทำไก่
ทอดเป็นไหมคะ
[เพลง]
คิดนี้หานา
ทำเป็น 50% ได้มั้ย
เดี๋ยว
ผู้หญิงมีคำถ้าถามว่าทำไมไม่คำถามครูฟ้า
บอกว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำอันนี้ใช่ไหมไก่ทอด
น้ำคุณฟ้าบอกว่าทำไก่ทอดเป็นแต่เป็น
50%
ก็ซื้อไก่มาใช่ไหมเอามาใส่ซอสไงขอให้
คอร์สเออนั่นแหละคือ 50% ที่ทำได้อ๋อ
โอเคอันนี้เขาก็ถือว่า 100%  100%
100% ทำเป็นว่ากูฟ้าเข้าใจใช่ไหมว่าไก่
ทอดเนี่ย Step ที่ 1
ทำอะไร 2 ทำอะไร 3  4 สมัย Step ที่หนึ่ง
สเต็ปที่ 2  step ที่ 31 ที่ 4 ครู Fast
เนี่ยรู้กรุงรู้ว่าไก่ทอด
จะทำยังไงแล้วก็เสร็จออกมา
ไก่ทอดอันนี้ก็แปลว่าคู่ฟ้าทำไก่ทอดเป็น
100%
100% แล้วปรุงหินทำไก่ทอดเป็นไหมคะไปทอด
ชื่อไหมคะ
เป็นค่ะ
อร่อยไหม
มันง่ายๆใช่ไหมมีสเต็ปสเต็ปสเต็ปหน่อย
สายค่าถ้าครูหญิงทำไก่ทอดแล้วก็กินอ่ะ
มึงไม่อร่อยมีสอศ.
จิ้มสอศ.
อร่อย
มันง่ายหรอไก่ทอดมีใหญ่ทองเมนูต่อไปค่ะ
ครูฟ้าอะไรคะอันที่ 2 สีส้มตำหมู
ซุ้มปั้มน้ำส้มตำครูฟ้าตำส้มตำไม่ต้องตำ
เรอะเออครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ตำส้มตำเป็นไหมคะ
ไม่เป็นฮ่าๆถูกใจอะไรคะ
ไม่เป็นไม่เป็น
ไรอ่ะ
หนคนทำต้องตำเป็นเหรอ
ว่าคุยกับครูฟ้าใช่ผู้หญิงรู้รู้จักครู
ฟ้าไงครูฟ้าเป็นคนทำอาหาร
อร่อยนาก็เลยคิดครูฟ้าต้องตำส้มตำเป็น
กำลังใจทำไม่เป็นก็มีเคยทำไง
ไม่เคยทำผู้จะตำส้มตำเป็นไหมคะเป็นค่ะ
ไม่ธรรมดา
ำส้มต่อมเป็นอร่อยไหม
ผู้หญิงกินอร่อยแต่คิดว่าถ้าครูฟ้าหรือ
ว่านักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยกินส้ม
ตำที่กูหญิงตามเนี่ยนะคะน่าจะไม่อร่อย
ก็เลยคิดกูหญิงคิดอร่อยนะส้มตามใจตามชอบ
ทำเป็นนะเข้าใจเคยตั้มตั้งแต่เด็กๆเนาะ
ไฟฟ้าตำส้มตำไม่เป็นให้ปิด
อันนี้ละกันว่าเมนูนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ชอบกินนักฟ้าชอบกินข้าว
มาเอาผัดกระเพราครูฟ้าทำผัดกระเพราอันนี้
ก็คือเอา
อันนี้นะคะผัดกระเพรานะคะครูฟ้าทำผัด
กระเพราเป็นไหมคะ
ครูบาทำผัดกระเพราเป็นเหงาเป็นแล้วอร่อย
ไหมเวลากินแล้วหรอกอุ๊ย
แน่นอนอร่อยงูทำเป็นผู้หญิงทำผัดกระเพรา
เป็นไหมคะเป็นค่ะค่ะทำเป็น
อร่อยไหมรอยอันนี้คิดอร่อยเพราะมันต้องมี
Story นะหนู Story หรอทำไมรู้ได้ที่ไหน
ว่านี้อันนี้คุณพ่อใช่ไหมคุณแม่แล้วก็อัน
นี้ครูหญิงนะคะพี่หญิงเนี่ยมีน้องชายน้อง
ทรายใช่ต่อไปผู้หญิงแล้วก็น้องน้องๆๆกูก็
ไม่ตอบตอนผู้หญิงอายุซะ 13 วันนี้ก็ 12
วันนี้สิขวบยังไงอ่ะกูก้อนมาก่อนเนาะคุณ
พ่อไปออฟฟิศคุณแม่ไปออฟฟิศ
น้องชายบอกคุณผู้หญิงทำผัดกระเพรา
อร่อย
ร้องใต้แต่น้องชาย 10 ขวบนะ
นานแล้วอยู่นานแล้วนะก็เลยทำผัดกระเพรา
เป็นแล้วก็ทำอร่อยนะคะโอเคโอเคเมนูต่อไป
ค่ะครูฟ้ารู้จักไหม
ออกปีอ่ะ
เปียทอดหรอที่ว่านักเรียนนักเรียนกิน
นะเมียทอดครูฟ้า
ติดต่อเปี๊ยกทอดเป็นไหมคะ
ไม่เป็นค่ะ
ไม่เป็นไม่เป็นไม่รู้ทำยังไงไม่เข้าใจ
เข้าใจผู้หญิงทําปอเปี๊ยะทอดเป็นไหมคะไม่
เป็นเหมือนกันค่ะน้องทำไม่เป็นไม่เข้าใจ
สเต็ปที่หนึ่งสเต็ปที่ 2 ทำอะไรเนาะของคน
คำไม่เป็นนี่ปิดยาก
ทำไม่เป็นเนาะ
ต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าอ่ะดีก็นักเรียนชอบกินนะคะ
อะไรฮะแกงเขียวหวานแกงเขียวหวาน
ครูซาร์ดทำแกงเขียวหวานเป็นไว้คะ
ครูฟ้าทำแกงเขียวหวานไม่เป็น
เอง
ไม่เป็นไม่เป็นครูผู้หญิงทำแกงเขียวหวาน
เป็นไหมคะครูหญิงทำแกงเขียวหวานไม่เป็น
ค่ะไม่เป็นไม่รู้ทำยังไงใส่อะไรนึง
ไม่รู้จักกัน
ไม่เป็นไม่เป็นเมนูต่อไปครูฟ้าชอบกิน
เหมือนกันอะไรอ่ะไข่เจี๊ยวดีเนาะไข่เจียว
นะคะมีที่ห้องหนูฟ้าทำไข่เจียวเป็นไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าทำไข่เจียวเป็นมิค่ะ
เวลากูฟ้าทำไข่เจียวเป็นทำกินแล้วเนี่ย
อ้ะหืออร่อยไหมมี
อร่อยนะคิดว่าอร่อย
ง่ายไงไข่เจียวทำง่ายทางผู้หญิงทำไข่
เจียวเป็นไหมคะเป็นค่ะถ้าทำเป็นทำไข่
เจียวเป็น
อร่อยไหมไม่อร่อย
เศร้าขนาดนั้น
ไม่อร่อยกูฟ้าพูด
ใช้เดียวเนี่ยง่ายๆเลยมีหนึ่งเจ็บที่
หนึ่งสเต็ปที่ 2  step ที่ 3 เสร็จแล้ว
เออสวยแตกผู้หญิงทำแล้วกิน
ไม่อร่อย
แต่ทำเป็นนะไม่อร่อยเอาไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็น
ไรให้กูฟ้าทำคู่หญิงกินนะคะ
เออโอเคอันนี้ครูสาวก็ชอบกินอีกแล้วค่ะ
ไข่กินทุกอย่างเลยนะคะ
พิซซ่าค่ะอาทิตที่บ้า
ครูฟ้าอาจทำพิซซ่าเป็นไหมคะครูฟ้าทำคลิป
ซ่าไม่เป็นค่ะ
เป็นได้ยังไงไม่ต้องเชฟบล็อคต้องแบบมือ
แฟชั่นแน่วระดับเคฟ
tf10 ฮะ
ผู้หญิงทำพิซซ่าเป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นไรค่ะไม่
เป็นไม่เข้าใจทำยังไงคิดว่ามีสเต็ปสเต็ป
สเต็ปสเต็ปสเต็ปเยอะๆหรอ pizza
โอเคโอเคต่อไป
อันนี้ละกันเมนูที่นักเรียนชอบกินก็คือ
ต้มยำกุ้ง
พี่
กุ้งนะคะต้มยำกุ้งครูฟ้าทำต้มยำกุ้งเป็น
ไหมคะ
ก็เหมือนต้มยำ
แค่ใส่กรุงใช่ไหมเป็นค่ะ
เป็นแล้วทำอร่อยไหม
ไม่ชัวร์นะ
ก็ YouTube ว่าอร่อย
อร่อยคิดแสวงอร่อยแต่แบบไม่แน่ใจอร่อย
หรือเปล่าตายผู้หญิงทำต้มยำกุ้งเป็นไหมคะ
คุณผู้หญิงไม่เป็นค่ะ
ไม่เข้าใจทำยังไงเนาะทำไม่เป็นนะทำต้มยำ
กุ้งไม่เป็น
โอเค
อันนี้ละกันจึงคิดว่าก็อาจจะสําเป็นระยะ
ไกลไหมหยัง
อันนี้อร่อยค่ะคือฝารู้ไหม
น้ำจิ้มซีฟู๊ดหรอจ่ายค่ะเป็นน้ำจิ้ม
ซีฟู๊ดใช่ไหมเป็นซอสเนาะ
สสเป็นน้ำจิ้มใส่เวลามีกุ้งเลี้ยงผู้เป็น
ซีฟู้ดคนไทยเอากุ้งแล้วก็มีน้ำจิ้มแล้ว
กุ้งอ่ะจิ้มก็
อร่อยใช่ไหมแบบไทยสายเนาะเราจิ้มซีฟู๊ด
ครูฟ้า
ทำน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดเป็นไหมคะ
เป็นค่ะแน่นอนหรอทำน้าอร่อยไหมอร่อยมาก
โอ้ย
อร่อย
มากผู้หญิงทำน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดเป็นไหมคะอ่ะมา
ถึงค่า
อร่อยไหมอร่อยมาก
อร่อยมาก
ของครูฟ้าเนี่ยอร่อยมากผู้หญิงอร่อยมาก
ท่านจัง
เพราะว่าเราเชื่อไหมชลบุรีพัทยามีซีฟู้ด
เยอะเราก็ทำน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดเป็นเนาะอร่อย
มีอีก 1 อย่างนะคะอันนี้ก็ไปค่ะ
คุกกี้
[เพลง]
คุกกี้เนาะครูฟ้าทำคุกกี้เป็นไหมคะ
รูปอ่าทำคุกกี้
ไม่เป็นค่ะคิดคิดนานหญิงคิดๆกุมภาทำ
คุกกี้เป็นหรือเปล่านะบ๊ายเป็น
สิ่งที่ไม่เป็น
ผู้หญิงทำคุกกี้เป็นไหมคะไม่เป็นค่ะ
เหมือนเป็นเหมือนครูฟ้าแต่ครูฟ้าบอกว่า
ครูฟ้าทำบราวนี่เป็นบราวนี่
จริงเปล่านี่ก็เป็นของฝรั่งของนักเรียน
เป็นช็อกโกแลตเหรอคะครูฟ้าให้หากเป็น
ช็อกโกแลตนี่เนาะแบบนี้ใช่ไหมเรานี่หรอ
น่าบราวนี่ครูฟ้าทำบราวนี่เป็นหรอคะทำ
บ่าวนี่เป็น
อร่อยไหมไม่ให้
การใช้ไมโครเวฟไมโครเวฟล่ำน้องก็เลยอาจจะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยทำบราวนี่สมัยทำเขาบอกว่าทำ
ครั้งที่ 1 เอ้อใช่มั้ยครั้งที่ 1 อาจจะ
แบบปลื้มไม่อร่อยโอเคครั้งที่ 2 สมัย
ครั้งที่ 2 ครั้งที่ 3
จะดีขึ้นดีขึ้นดีขึ้น
ต้องทำหลายๆครั้งเนาะใส่แล้วนะคะก็วันนี้
น้องเราสองคนก็คุยกันนะเกี่ยวกับการทำ
อาหารว่าทำเป็นหรือไม่เป็นนะคะแล้วนัก
เรียนทำอะไรเป็นก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะ
ใช้เดี๋ยววันนี้เราสองคนเจ้าไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเจอกันใหม่มีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายเฟิร์น
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ